we'll now look at chapter nine
which is on linear dynamical systems uh
it's an application area
um actually it's used in many many many
fields
so it's a very good thing to know about
and at its essence
it really only uses nothing but matrix
vector multiplication which is something
we know about now
okay so let's take a look so we'll start
with what is a linear dynamical system
and then we're going to look at two
practical examples now the examples i'm
going to show you are going to be a bit
simplified of course but it'll give you
a rough idea of how
real ones actually are done okay
so let's start with the setting so
i have a sequence of n vectors and we're
going to call those x1
x2 x3 and so on um
now here the index um denotes something
like the time
or the period um could be you know that
may be
something about it could measure time at
a fixed interval like
daily uh hourly but it doesn't have to
be it could be for example trading days
in finance um trading days and finance
you know doesn't count weekends and
market holidays
uh so that would be um that's what that
but basically t
the the subscript t uh here uh if you
have
x sub t a t is just a mnemonic supposed
to hint at time
that's the idea okay and these are n
vectors uh notice the notation's a bit
ambiguous right that
uh in this case the subscript doesn't
mean the teeth index
of the vector x it means x sub t which
is the t
vector in a sequence of vectors okay if
you want to talk about the third entry
of
x seven you write it like this
and the interpretation is that is the
third component
of x7 which is uh the state
at time t equals seven okay
so that's when xt is going to be called
the state
x is a traditional uh symbol for the
state but there's lots of others that
are used
and the sequence is called a state
trajectory a trajectory just tells you
how something evolves across time
and so that's what this is that's what
this is called it's a state trajectory
um now just to give you a rough idea of
how this works if t
is the current time say it's today or
something like that
then x t we refer to that as the current
state
it's the state at the time right now um
x sub t
minus 1 that's the previous state so for
example if this is
daily x sub t minus 1 is the state
yesterday x t plus 1
that's the next state so if this were
daily
xd plus 1 would be the state tomorrow
okay and xt what does it represent it
can represent many many many things but
for example we'll look at a couple of
examples but we'll look at one where it
represents the age
the age distribution in a population and
that means basically
the entries tell you how many people
there are in some population of a
certain age
and xt gives you the age distribution um
a very common one is in economics where
x t
the entries of xt give you the economic
output
in n sectors of the economy right so the
different entries of x
tell you how different sectors uh did in
that period
um and it's very common uh for
mechanical systems
uh to to describe this one there the
entries of x are typically
uh positions or displacements um and
also
uh they could they will typically
include also velocities and momentum
okay so but the idea right now is it's
just a vector
sequence okay now
linear dynamics uh is this um
it's a very special form it says x t
plus one
is atxt and that simply says that
the next state is obtained from the
current state
by simply multiplying by a matrix okay
another matrices can vary with time
that's what this sub t is here and a sub
t
that's an n by n matrix it's usually
called the dynamics matrix or the update
matrix dynamics is pretty uh
it is very common term uh to refer to
this right
and we can interpret uh now there's a
lot of a lot of indices flying around
here so you have to be very
very careful um so for example
a t sub ij so t is denotes the time
or the period oh another name for timer
period is
epoch so i don't know it's an old old
name for it but
okay um then i j are of course the
entries
uh in the in the n by n matrix a sub t
and and so the i j entry tells you how
much the j
uh input uh to the matrix vector
multiplication affects the
output so for example here if you have x
t that's the state at time t or epic t
it's the j component then you multiply
these two together
and you get the contribution to the ith
component of
tomorrow's or well that's if it's daily
but the next state um
component i that comes from the current
state component
j okay so that's the that's the
interpretation
this is quite tricky there are a lot of
indices here
and you really gotta be gotta sit down
and go real slow and try to understand
what
all these things mean okay
now in many many cases a does not depend
on time
and so it is it is what people would say
it's either it's constant
or you would say that it is time
invariant
um and then you would refer to this if
you if it looks like this
x t plus one equals to simply a
x t we say that we would we would say
that this is a linear time
invariant dynamical system
okay so that's something you'll hear and
sometimes you'll hear the phrase
lti for linear time invariant
dynamical system okay
now one thing to say right now is of
course many things
are not many dynamical systems do not
evolve according to these equations
but it turns out a lot of them do either
pretty approach pretty well or or at
least
approximately and what one thing to
notice immediately
is that you can interpret this as a
recursion
and what that says for example is if i
knew the current state
i could simply multiply by a t get x d
plus one
i multiply that by a t plus a t
plus one and i'd get x t plus two and so
on and so these are just make iterated
matrix vector multiplications
and in fact that's called simulating uh
the evolution
of the state if you said that anyone
would understand what you're talking
about
so um and that's very cool you could do
things like say
um please simulate the system forward 10
time periods right or please
please tell me uh what this mechanical
system is going to be doing
in the next one second when i'm when
i've sampled
at a rate of let's say uh 50 times a
second right so i would
i would propagate forward 50 time steps
to see what what what configuration it
will be and what the state will be
so so you can actually uh basically
simulate
a linear dynamical system
now there are a lot of variations a very
very common one
looks like this um this is the usual
update is the a t
plus that that's that's the contribution
to the next state from the current state
but then people put on something another
term which is bt
ut and then even ct that's less common
but
does happen now here ut is an m
vector uh u is in fact the traditional
symbol
and it's supposed to be an input so ut
is an input
to the dynamical system and ct
is an offset right so for i'll give you
an example
is aircraft dynamics is described by
this actually with ct
equal to zero ut is a vector
that tells you about the various things
you can do to control the airplane for
example
what are the angles of the control
surfaces like the rudder
elera ailerons elevator things like that
right so that's what that is or one
might be the engine thrust
so it would it would tell you things
like if you were to increase your thrust
what would happen if you were to
turn your rudder you know left two
degrees like what would happen
okay and that's a that that has a model
like that in fact
that's such a that's a very common model
actually for all of
what's called modern control and for
that matter of navigation
that there's entire courses on nothing
but
this linear dynamic system right so at
stanford we have one
that's ee263 okay
so b is referred to as the input matrix
here u is the input
usually in those applications u is
something we might have control over and
so the natural questions you'd ask
would be what would be a good sequence
of inputs to apply to my system
actually we'll be able to answer all of
those questions um
in a few weeks in this course so we'll
be able to get a very good idea
uh hold on that okay um
another common version is uh is
something like this
this is a the so-called k markov model
um and what it says is that the next
state
that's xt plus one is a
uh actually it's a sum of contributions
from the current state
the previous state the previous previous
date and so on and this goes back
uh k steps um and in fact sometimes
people call that the memory of the
system because basically it says that
the next state
depends not just on the current state
that would be a linear simple basic
linear dynamical system but in fact
it depends on the current state the
previous state and maybe you know going
back or something like that so that's
called
that's sometimes called the memory of
such a system
and this is called k markov model
it's also called another context like in
statistics auto regressive
or vector auto regressive so var model
it's got lots of names
um okay so that's a that's an auto
regressive model
and when capital k is one that's the
memory um
this uh this corresponds to just a
linear dynamical system
yeah oh i should i should stop and tell
you just one quick story about what
state means so the there's
there is a definition of state and what
state means is it's an it's a
summary of what you need to know about
the past
to be able to predict the future that's
what the state is
and if we go back here you'll see that
that's exactly what this
does so for example if i said you know
please please show me the next three
states like
x t plus 1 x d plus 2 x t plus 3.
all you have to know is x t you don't
have to know when x t minus 1 was
x t minus 2 it is no one's business how
the system got into the state x t
because once you have x t
you multiply by a t and you get x t plus
one then you multiply that
by a t plus one and you get x t plus two
and so on
so the point is that x t really is a
bona fide
summary of the past
sufficient to allow you to predict the
future
right so some people would call it a
sufficient statistic or something like
that
okay and in a k markov model
the state uh people would not call like
see the state here the state is
actually it's the collection you know x
t x t minus one
down to x t minus k plus one okay
so what we're going to do now is uh look
at two examples in a little bit of
detail
now obviously they're going to be
simplified but they should give you a
pretty good idea of
how these things come up how and where
these come
up linear dynamical systems and the
first one is population dynamics
and we'll go over it and figure it and
by the way once you've seen these models
there's lots of variations on them and
you'll be able to get all of it
let's just jump right in so here it is
what we're going to do
is t is going to be years so
and we don't mean the year one a d uh we
mean
you know the year relative to some fixed
year
like this year or 2010 something like
that
okay and then xd is a 100 vector so it's
100 entries 100 long
and what it is it's going to represent
the number of people
with a certain age and the ages are
going to go 0
1 up to 99. and for simplicity we're
simply going to assume
that no one lives to be more than 99 of
course that's not the case
when people build real models like this
they actually go up to like 115
just just to kind of cover essentially
that point everyone
okay but just for fun hundreds of clean
number we just assume
everyone is between 0 and 99 years old
okay um
so x x t
uh one is the number of zero year olds
people who are not yet one um and
x t let's say 12
is the number of 11 year olds okay so
that's how that's going to work
and that's in that's in time period t or
sorry
year t okay so for example if you wanted
to get the total population
that's uh one transpose xt so that's the
vector of all ones
so you know that if you take the inner
product of the ones vector and a vector
you sum all the entries and so this is
adding up everyone
who is alive right so it's ever everyone
who has an age between 0 and 99. in our
model there's no one alive
older than 99. okay
but if you wanted other things it's like
for example
this this vector i should say what that
is uh that is
uh concatenation of two vectors or
stacking um and first we stack
70 zeros on top of them 31s and what
that's going to give you
is the total it's going to sum uh x71
uh x72 x73 all the way up to x00
and that's all the people who are age 70
or older okay so uh for example
if we were to simulate xt out several
years and then
ask you know how many people will be
older older will be 70 or older in five
years from now
this is these are the ways we would do
it or how many people would be
high school age for example you could
construct another vector here
that would pick out the people of a
certain age range and
it would give you that okay so that
that's this is the idea so now you know
what the state is
um and you know what t is it's it's
years okay
so uh this is from the 2010 uh census
in the u.s um and it shows the age
distribution
of people of different ages and i mean i
don't know you can look at there's
people who study this and who know a lot
about
demographics and things like that but
it's kind of interesting you can see
that there's
kind of a of a constant number of people
up to about age i don't know up to well
let's just go
let's go out to here give him a benefit
of doubt um maybe
late 50s right then
sorry this is yeah by the way some of
this is going to get kind of uh
more okay so then you can see that this
thing drops off and
well that's because people are dying
okay so um
so let's see for example uh by the time
let's see um let's see by the time you
hit 70
you know roughly speaking sadly
i guess about you know you get about
half the number of people who were
who who are between roughly zero and 50
right so that's the age distribution the
in in the u.s right
by the people who study demography would
know what you know this is
they'd say oh yes that's the that's the
baby boom i mean i don't know actually
honestly but i mean
they would they would they could
actually point to various things and say
yeah that
we know what that is and all that kind
of stuff okay so this is the picture oh
and this is
xt so this is actually specifically we
if t were
if t equals 1 means 2010 this would be
x1 this is the vector we're just
plotting it right okay
now the way the number of people in the
u.s
propagate from year to year um oh and i
should say
that we're going to ignore immigration
and immigration right so we're going to
ignore that entirely
although one could easily include that
that would be an additional term like
the ut
that we talked about earlier but we're
not going to now just to keep it simple
so uh well so you know how does it
propagate and we have to ask ourselves
the question
how what let's see what is the
population distribution
next year given the population
distribution this year
and so uh well let's see let's figure it
out i mean basically it's going to go
like this
so how many zero year olds will there be
next year well the answer is
basically those are the people who were
born that year because anybody who has
already counted last year is going to be
at least one
on the next uh is going to be at least
one on the next time
okay in the next time step so so
basically
the next year the first
the you know xt plus one sub one is the
number of people who were born
that year um now how many people are age
next year that's got a pretty simple
answer
it's the people who are 26 this year
sadly
uh minus those who died that year so
and yes 26 year olds do die it's very
sad
the good news is it's pretty rare but
nevertheless some do
and so the number of 27 year olds next
year would be equal to the number 26
this year and then maybe you'd have to
subtract off the people who died the
small number of people okay
so that's that's explained uh that's
going to be by that that we're going to
explain
by the so-called um that the the death
rate
and d i that's going to be the portion
of those who are h i minus one
um who end up dying this year and
therefore don't don't make it you know
don't count
in in the next uh next year they're not
around
right and we'll take d100 equals one
that kind of means
at least in our simple model once you
get to be 90 uh once you get to be 99
you'll die period
okay um okay now the uh the other one is
the birth rate and the birth rate
is a vector uh in our 100 and
um what it says it's going to tell us
the birth rate is going to tell us
how many people are born to people
of that age okay so and there's some
pretty obvious things you would know
about that and we'll we'll
look at both of these things uh we will
end shortly
i should say that in fancy population
dynamics models
both the birth rate and the death rate
um have also changed with time
for various reasons um all
social reasons but uh you know uh health
technology advances
and things like that but we're gonna
just assume they're constant
okay so these are uh
birth and death rates uh in in the us
um i think that the
birth rate i think is given in five-year
chunks but whatever
here it is and uh you can see a lot of
things yes so guess what not
surprisingly there are
uh no children uh born uh two uh zero to
ten year olds or i should say what you
know one to
we have one to ten year olds um and
there's also basically zero important to
people
i mean at least visually on the plot
doesn't look like that you know people
people age 50 or 60 don't you know and
and older are not having kids okay and
you can see the big bump here and it
i guess it uh it peaks in the us between
25 and 30.
right so that that's what this is right
right here right here and
and it says that it's about i don't know
a little shy of five percent so that
means if you
are i don't know 27 and uh
you're in the u.s then uh
just under five percent uh of you
will have a kid that year uh by the way
that's not going to include the men
obviously so
if it's about 50 50 that's somewhere
around nine percent right
of of women will have a a baby in the
u.s
at age 27. okay now let's look at the
death rate um that is this vector d
and we're writing it in percentage and
what it says
is it says that i mean it's not
surprising it says the death rate is
very low until you get to be i don't
know 55
and then you can see it starts going up
and up and up
so i'm about right here by the way just
in case anyone's curious
um so i'm right at the beginning of the
hill
okay which is i guess not cool for me or
something anyway
so um so what happens then
is uh you know like by the time you get
to 80
or 90 yeah it's for 90 it's about 10
right so um maybe even more that's like
87 but anyway for 90
yeah it's probably something like uh 12
percent of 90 year olds are going to die
in the next year
so um that's the idea so this plot looks
kind of like what you'd expect it to
look it it kind of makes sense
um oh and over here you see a little
tiny thing
there um that's real and what it is is
that
uh some people refer to a death rate
that goes down
is flat and goes up again as the bathtub
or something like that i mean here it's
not very pronounced right
but um it basically says that there are
a lot of infants
uh you know very young people who die
between zero and two
or something like that um certainly uh
50 years ago this was much more
pronounced right or a hundred years ago
it was definitely more pronounced a lot
of kids just didn't make it like in the
19th century for example
so okay but the point is these pass the
the test of being reasonable i mean
they're correct they're
they're from the sense u.s census so
there they
there they are okay
now we're going to construct the
dynamics and that means we're going to
construct
this 100 by 100 matrix
that maps the current u.s population
density
into next year's population density and
the way we're going to do that is pretty
simple is the number of
zero year olds next year is the total
births this year now that's equal to
just that's the inner product
i take i take the birth rate vector
that's b
it's a hundred vector and i take the
inner product of that with x t
right because b uh well let me give it a
real one
b 25 is actually the
number it's the it's the number of it's
the number of kids
that a 25 year old is going to have now
it's small it's point .03 or something
like that
um but then i multiply by the number of
23 year olds or what 25 year olds
whatever i chose
right and then we get the whole thing
and you add all that up and you get this
okay um no not surprisingly
b is zero between like zero and ten and
certainly above seventy or something
so it says that zero to ten year olds
and people above seventy are not pulling
their weight in terms of having kids
right but that's i guess well that's
biology so okay
all right so and that gives you x
x t plus one sub one because x t plus
one is next
means next year's population
distribution sub one means the number of
zero year olds
okay so and it's simply equal to b
transpose x
okay now the number of i year olds next
year
is going to be the number of i minus one
year olds this year
minus those who die right and if the
death rate is di
it says that x t plus 1 i plus 1 and you
really have to
like read these very carefully because
otherwise you know it's very confusing
this says the population distribution at
next year
sub i plus 1 that's the number of i year
olds next year and that's equal to the
number
the current number of i minus 1 year
olds
that would be this thing minus the
fraction who die
and that's going to be minus di so it
looks like this and this is true for i
equals 1 up to 99. and so if we assemble
all of this into a matrix we get
this matrix here which is a is this
thing the
top row tells you about the is the birth
is literally the birth rate then the
next rows are very interesting
each row only has one non-zero entry um
so for example uh and by the way that
makes sense
let's actually interpret what that means
and you can check you can put an x
t here right and this becomes
x t plus 1 and you can just kind of work
out that
see that it makes sense but let me just
say a couple things about this matrix a
by the way it has a name i mean you
don't need to know it but it's called a
companion matrix
a matrix that's got a you know a row
that's non-zero and then kind of a
sub-diagonal that's non-zero
doesn't matter oh it's a super sparse
matrix i hope you notice that because
it's 100 100 matrix so there's 10 000
entries
in that in in total entries in that
matrix and yet
only 199 are only 199 of them
are uh are non-zero so you know when a
matrix has only 199 non-zeros out of 10
000 it's sparse so that's a sparse
that's a sparse matrix
also let's interpret a couple things
like each row here
mysteriously only has one non-zero
what does that mean well what it means
is this
a row tells you how do you get next
year's
number of people of a certain age right
and
what this says is there's only one way
to make a 28 year old there's the only
way to make a 28 year old it's got to be
someone who was 27 last year
like period that's it so so that also
kind of makes sense
um you can look at
columns right so columns are interesting
if i look at a column here
it's super duper interesting if i look
at let's say the
the 29th column that corresponds to
people who are 28
and uh the top entry
tells me how many kids did they have
right and then if i go down here i'll
find another entry which basically is a
number slightly less than one which
tells us
basically those 28 year olds are going
to be
29 next year except for the small
fraction who die
okay so that's that's the picture so
there's your there's your matrix it's x
t plus one is a
x of t and we're going to assume it's
time invariant um
if you do real demographic studies uh
you do
you actually predict that these things
are changing over time i should also add
in real demographic studies you would do
this for sub populations and kind of
estimate them differently or something
like that but
this is a basic population dynamics
model and it's a linear dynamical system
okay so um here's
what we do uh so we can actually now do
a simulation
um now this is the this is the
simulation
uh and let me explain how i got it uh we
started
with this that's the population
distribution of the u.s in the 2010
uh census right so that we'll just
assume that that's correct
right um okay so we take that and we
then multiply it by this matrix
a which is our dynamics matrix that
gives us the 2011
distribution not by the way not the
exact distribution but
sort of our model's prediction of it
then i multiply by a again and i
multiply i multiplied by a
10 times and i get
this okay so that's the that is our
prediction of the 2020 distribution
and that's ignoring uh immigration and
emigration
okay so um okay so that's interesting by
the way
the current year is 2020 and the census
is being carried out right now
um so we could have a drum roll when the
census is done and compare this plot
to what the us uh to what the us says it
really is
honestly it's probably going to be
pretty close when we uh ignore
immigration and things like that um
it won't be it won't be exactly right
but it'll be pretty close
um and you see all yeah you see
interesting stuff here
uh that's it you can look at it and and
and make you know demographers would
make a big deal about
you know like what is this thing and i
don't know what's that or what
i don't know so they would say but they
would have lots of interesting things to
say about it so this is the kind of idea
now i'll just mention a few things about
how
you know i mean it's completely clear
that this is useful i mean extremely
clear right
because for example if you were a school
district you might ask
how many kids are going to be in high
school
10 years from now because if it's going
to be a lot more
than currently we may have to float a
bond
build another school something like that
so that's the kind of thing
you might do or you might ask yourself
how many people will be
retired in the next 15 years right
because that would be
uh that that that could tell you i mean
so there's all sorts of stuff you could
do with uh
with with models like this but this is
the basic idea
okay our next topic is epidemic
dynamics that is uh
well it's it's quite topical because i'm
sitting here all alone
recording lectures which is frankly
ridiculous but i'm doing it precisely
because
we have a pandemic raging especially in
the united states i should add
so here i am doing so this is actually
quite topical
i should say that this this example was
in the book
and in the course you know for the last
couple of years so this was not
prescient or anything
but what i'll do is show you how it's
another example of how
linear dynamical systems are used to
model
certain things once again this is an
incr what i'm going to show you is a
highly simplified epidemic
epidemic dynamic model but nevertheless
it's one that kind of gets some cool
i mean it kind of gives you it would it
would be a good start uh so let's take a
look at that
um we'll look at something super simple
it's called the sir model
and what it does is your
your state is a vector uh it's and it's
got four entries and that's it
and they are uh there is it's a number
it's the proportion of a population
which is susceptible like that so that
means if you're susceptible it means
that you don't have immunity
and well you're not dead okay so
in which case you're not susceptible um
you could be infected
right that's another fraction um and
that means you actively have the disease
on in that in in on that time period you
actually have the disease
um recovered means you had the disease
and you're now immune okay so that's
kind of again the
the the idea and then finally we have
deceased that's the number of people who
had the disease and unfortunately
died okay so we have um and
this is this is called um sir model
there's
many many many other models much more
sophisticated and so on
so for example if i told you that xt was
that number
we would say well in that population 75
percent of the population
is susceptible meaning they could they
could catch the disease
10 actually actively have the disease
at time period t another 10 percent
had the disease and they've recovered
and they're now immune
and very sadly five percent that's the
0.05 here
actually had the disease and are dead
they died so this is the this this is
what this vector
uh means okay so uh
okay so epidemic dynamics so here's
the model a very very elementary model
goes like this
it says we're going to do daily so on
every day it says the following
um for every among the susceptible
population
five percent actually acquire the
disease right and 95
don't they just remain susceptible right
so um
by the way these are the kind of
interesting things you could do if
people like for example wore masks or
something like that
or practice social distancing you can
push the five percent down to maybe
two percent or one percent if you're
lucky right that's kind of thing
um okay um but we'll just say it's five
percent
um now among the infected population
here's what happens on each day
um very sadly one percent of them dies
so among all the people who are infected
on a given day
about one percent of them die um now ten
percent however recover
so it means on the next day you're
recovered
um and you have immunity um now we can
also have this
four percent recover that's good um but
they recover
without immunity right and so that's
just and i'm just making this up it's
just an example i'm making up
um and that means that they're back to
being susceptible
and 85 just remain if you're infected
today
you'll be infected tomorrow right and
you will not transition to any of these
other
other statuses um and let's see
if you are immune today your immune
uh your immune uh you're gonna be immune
tomorrow uh by the way we could we could
change this to 0.99
and now 99 that'd be very interesting
and you could transition from immune to
susceptible
and that would mean that every day one
percent of people who
are immune actually become susceptible
again okay so that's i'm just saying we
could do that we're not going to we're
just gonna say
once you have immunity it's forever okay
um oh and of course if you're dead today
you will be dead tomorrow that's part of
the model that's actually pretty
realistic assumption i think okay
so now when you assemble this together
uh you basically have to say
what is the next state
has a function of this state and you
have to write it as a matrix a
that doesn't have to be called a can be
called anything you like and you're
going to multiply it
by the current state okay and so here's
what you get
um so we got this matrix here it's four
by four it's 16 numbers
there's a bunch of zeros in it but let's
audit some of it and make sure we
understand it
so let's see what is this number well
that number tells you uh it says that
this multiplies
the first entry this is this is today's
state and the first entry of that is
going to be the people who are
susceptible
and it says that that
it said it and it contributes to who is
susceptible
on the on the next uh day and this says
that you multiply by 0.95 the number of
people susceptible today and that'll be
the number of people susceptible
uh the next time or the contribution
from them there's also this one
which is super cool the second one are
the people who have immunity
and this says that oh sorry who have the
disease who are infected
and four percent of them uh go back to
being susceptible and that's what this
component is uh let's just check another
one let's see what what does that one
mean
that's zero let's audit it and make sure
we know by the way what we're doing here
is super important
um you know don't ever just write stuff
down and say
oh cool yeah i mean look at the numbers
audit take a random
entry and see if you and make absolutely
certain you can understand it so let's
look at this one
that says um who is going
to be this says uh how many
what is what is the number of deceased
people uh
as a function of um of the current state
susceptible now in our model we don't
have people going from susceptible
to dead actually you could easily
that could be you know some very small
number and that's people who died
not from the disease so this doesn't
have to be zero it's zero in our model
but it could be some very small number
that
tells you about people dying other you
know by other
non-disease related deaths right um
let's see oh here we go what's this one
this one says that if you look at the
number of people today
that's gonna or the fraction of people
today who are infected and then it says
you multiply 0.01 and that's the number
of people who die
uh over the next day right so this is
okay so i'll leave that
here um and anyway so it's very
important and you should probably take
some time to actually audit
essentially all the entries in there to
make sure you understand them but
the point is now we have a beautiful
linear dynamical system
you know i i can start i can start for
example with everybody
uh susceptible and then just propagate
it forward and we'll just see
we can make predictions about uh
how long how long is it going to last
what's going to be the ultimate effect
all sorts of stuff like that
so um so here we go we are going to
start
with a purely 100 susceptible
group of people no one has immunity
that's it so everyone is susceptible and
i'm simply going to multiply
i mean it's very simple the simulation i
just run a loop i multiply
that vector by this matrix and i get the
fraction
after one step right um by the way that
fraction will be the first column
because x the x1 is if
if x1 is e1 that's what this says here
that's e1
then you multiply by a and you get the
first column so after one step
we know what it is then i multiply by a
again and again and again
and let's just take a look at what
happens well it's it's kind of cool
so here's what happens uh there's a
whole everyone is susceptible
very quickly the infections ramp up
um now what's kind of cool
is the the infections top out at about
of the population um right
and then they start going down um uh
they're go and you might ask why and
you'd say
well probably for a couple of reasons
one is depressing
one is that some people just died and
they're no longer susceptible and
they're not going to get the disease
but the other thing is that among all
the people who are infected a bunch
become recovered and recovered and
acquire immunity and that's this green
curve so this is
when you hear people talking about herd
immunity i guess they're
they're talking about you know some some
some effect like over here or something
that that that's kind of the idea